[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: I'm from Russia.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm from China.
MALE SPEAKER: We're from
Brunei dar as-Salaam.
FEMALE SPEAKER: New York.
MALE SPEAKER: Armenia.
MALE SPEAKER: London.
MALE SPEAKER: Saudi Arabia.
MALE SPEAKER: San Francisco,
California.
MALE SPEAKER: It's great.
It's exciting, actually.
VIC GUNDOTRA: On behalf of
Google, welcome to the Sixth
Annual Google I/O.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
VIC GUNDOTRA: It's really
not about us.
It's about you, developers,
who are building the most
amazing and magical experiences
that make those
platforms and services
come alive.
MALE SPEAKER: I always walk
away inspired to do more.
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
back to Google
Developers Live at I/O 2013.
SUNDAR PICHAI: We are in the
middle of one of the most
pivotal moments in personal
computing.
At the heart of this journey is
the impact we can have on
people around the world.
Android started with a simple
goal of bringing open
standards to the mobile
industry.
Today, it is the most popular
mobile operating
system in the world.
HUGH BARRA: Google Play
has just crossed
48 billion app installs.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
HUGH BARRA: We're here to show
that we're listening.
And we're here because we really
want you to thrive.
Today we're announcing a new
family of APIs built
specifically for game
developers, not only on
Android, but also for iOS
and web, so you can have
cross-platform gaming
experiences, which I think is
pretty cool.
TOR NORBYE: So what if I want to
know what this layout looks
like on different
screen sizes?
Let's take a look.
ELLIE POWERS: We're now
going to use our new
app translation service.
Professional translations
directly in
the developer console.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Chrome started
as a simple journey to make
the web much better, both as a
platform for developers, and
as an experience for users.
LINUS UPSON: A browser's
a means, not an end.
And so we're always trying to
figure out how to make the
browser smaller and faster.
SUNDAR PICHAI: Our goal with the
pixel was to get it in the
hands of developers, so that
they can build the next
generation of web experiences.
MALE SPEAKER: On the floor,
I think the best thing was
always being able to talk
to the engineers.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Everything
is very, very exciting.
MALE SPEAKER: Google is
innovating at such a
blistering speed,
it's incredible.
MALE SPEAKER: If you are
actively involved or very
interested in anything that
Google does, this is where you
need to be.
VIC GUNDOTRA: We're introducing
41 new features
across three major
areas of Google+.
A newly designed stream, a new
hang outs application, and a
fundamentally new photos
experience.
CHRIS YERGA: Today I'm happy to
announce Google Play Music
All Access, a uniquely Google
approach to a subscription
music service.
JONAH JONES: This is the
new Google Maps.
BERNI SEEFELD: And
those clouds?
They're real time.
Let's take a closer look.
No plug-ins, no downloads.
AMIT SINGHAL: A computer you can
talk to and it will answer
everything you ask it?
JOHANNA WRIGHT: OK, Google,
show me things
to do in Santa Cruz.
SIRI: Here are popular
attractions in Santa Cruz.
JOHANNA WRIGHT: Show
me my pictures from
New York last year.
AMIT SINGHAL: With the simple
touch of a mic, from the Queen
of England to the most common
farmer in Africa, everyone can
easily access all of humanity's
information.
LARRY PAGE: The opportunities
we have are tremendous.
You know, we haven't seen this
rate of change in computing
since the birth of personal
computers.
I think we're all here because
we share a deep sense of
optimism about the potential
of technology to improve
people's lives and the world.